Hi, and
welcome to another session of webcasts.
I'm.
>> I'm John.
>> And today,
John is going to help us set up Grunt.
>> Yeah, so for those of you who don't
really know what Grunt is, it's a task
runner build tool that does like all
this super awesome stuff for us.
And it's going to really make your
workflow just that much faster.
It kind of takes care
of all the grunt work.
Pun totally intended.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It takes care of all the mundane
form things that you have to do when
you're developing front-end code but
don't really want to
spend all the time doing.
So things like minifying your files,
right?
File size is a big, big problem
in web design, and you want to
get rid of all that white space and
just make it as small as possible.
Grunt will handle that for you.
It'll handle compiling any
sort of special code you use.
So if you use any sort of CSS
pre-processors like STASH or
Stylus or if you use any sort of
compiled JavaScript language like
Coffee Script or TypeScript.
It will handle all
the compilation of those.
It will also concat your
JavaScript files together so
users don't have to request a bunch
of JavaScript files all at once.
They can just.
>> So it helps with optimizations too.
Yes, optimizations too.
It'll optimize for you.
You can even set up your
Git workflow with it.
So you can link it up to GitHub,
add some Git commands into it.
And then you can just type in
Grunt Git and it'll log in,
push changes, merge changes.
So basically, if you find yourself doing
a repetitive task over and over agian in
your front end development, you could
probably get Grunt to do it for you.
>> Okay, sorry,
I feel like there's a lag.
>> There might be a little bit of a lag.
We'll see if that comes up.
But yeah, so that's kind of
the cool thing about Grunt.
It just let's you really focus in on
what's the most important part and
what you should really be focusing on,
which is your coding.
And then you get to avoid all the boring
stuff that you don't really want to do.
But there is a bit of
a learning curve to Grunt and
I think a lot of people
struggle with this at first.
It's actually a really simple
tool once you get it set up and
once you start playing around with.
And so I'm going to pretty much spend
probably the next 30 to 40 minutes
going over how to install
Grunt on your system.
How to set up a basic Grunt file and
some other little cool things
you can do with Grunt.
>> And then Grunt will come in handy
if our student [INAUDIBLE] for
project four.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> [INAUDIBLE] to the website
[INAUDIBLE] optimization n projects and
also [INAUDIBLE] project.
>> Yeah, and I mean it's pretty much
is a fairly standard tool, Grunt, or
the other popular one is Gulp.
Yeah.
>> You like that one better don't you?
And I won't dive into all
the reasons why I love Gulp better.
Grunt is still is a very,
very popular task runner.
It's, in fact,
more popular than Gulp still,
and it's really easy to use.
So how about we switch
over to my screen.
>> Good.
>> And
we'll start talking a little
bit about how to use Grunt.
>> Let's start with the wallpaper.
>> Yes that awesome wallpaper is
very motivational [INAUDIBLE].
It's sucking at something is the first
step at being sort of good at something.
I think that is really
how I feel about Grunt.
I totally sucked at Grunt at first.
I used it for one thing,
I couldn't even get it it set up
the first time I ever used it.
And then the more I started using it,
the better and better I got at it, and
the more useful of a tool it became.
>> So there's something to
let you all know is that we
posted the Github repo that
John is going to work off of.
>> Yeah, so
in the front end broadcast section of
the discussion forum about this event.
I included a, if you scroll down
a little bit, a post there.
And I don't know why it's opening twice.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> There is a Grunt workflow guide and
so you can go ahead and clone this,
download it as a zip, fork it,
whatever you want to do.
This is going to be the repository
that I'm working through today.
And.
>> And the link is also posted in
the description section [INAUDIBLE].
>> Yes, yes.
And so, in particular, the thing you're
probably going to want to look at is the
commits I'm going to be going through.
So each of the commits is
a different step in what we're
going to be doing today.
And the first commit
is the start commit.
And if you want your project
just start at this commit,
I should have done this before.
>> John, you have a student that
has the same wall paper as you.
>> Awesome.
I love it.
>> I apologize if Tron,
I'm not sure how to pronounce.
>> Khan.
Comtron.
>> Comtron?
>> Yep.
I love this wallpaper.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
if you want to start at the beginning
as well after you clone this repo
or you download it as a zip or whatever.
If you do, git actually let's
make this a little bit easier.
If you go to
the Grunt Workflow Guide on here and
just hit this little commits thing,
then go to the very first commit here.
I'm just making this
as easy as possible.
You can do it all from the command line,
using like GitLog, or GitGrapgh, and
things like that.
But you just copy this comment
number in the top right and
you get check out, and
then comment number.
And then that will get us are a lot of
give us just all the base stub files.
So this pretty much just has my source
directory, which has JS and SASS folder.
And in my JS folder
there's just two little
JavaScript files that probably
don't do anything fun, and
one little SASS file that just
has one little style in it.
I kept things simple, so
we're not doing a whole lot, but
it's easy to just expand these
ideas to the bigger topic.
So let's take a look then at how
do we actually install Grunt.
So the first thing we actually need
to do is we actually need to install
Node.js.
So Node.js is a fancy
asynchronous IO language that
some very, very smart people wrote.
It basically does
a whole bunch of stuff.
I'm not going to go
into all the details.
It's pretty simple to install.
You just click the Install.
It's going to download
something on your computer.
And then you just run the, will install
it and it sets itself up pretty well.
>> And it's pretty okay on both-
>> Yeah.
>> Macs and Windows?
>> So on Mac, it will basically install
itself right into your user bin folder.
So, you can run it right from
the terminal usually from the get-go.
So from here if I type, node which npm,
it tells me which npm I'm using.
On Windows I believe it
installs a Node shell client,
Node PowerShell.
And from there you basically
just open up that Bash or GUI,
whatever they call it.
Been a while since I've
taken a look at it.
But you basically just do all
your Node work from there.
It's just like having a terminal.
Most of the commands are the same.
And yeah, so
that's the first thing you need.
The first thing you need is Node.
The next thing is, I would always say
take a look at the Grunt website.
They have a great follow along,
getting started guide.
But, it maybe doesn't
explain a lot of things.
The most important thing though that
you need to do is you need to install
the command line interface.
And you do that pretty simply.
After you install Node, you'll have
access to the Node package manager.
>> Sorry to interrupt.
But, this is just grunt.js.com?
>> Yes, yes.
>> So, if you want to open that.
>> And so you want to do npm install,
and then you can choose to
not install it globally.
So this command here, this -g is going
to install this globally on my system.
And, then you just type in grunt-cli,
and so, npm is the Node package manager.
It's going to handle getting
all the files that you need,
installing them to
the proper directories.
And if you guys do you run
into any trouble at this step,
for whatever reason,
like it says npm isn't defined or
you're getting any kind of errors,
feel free to post in the forums.
I'll be happy to help sort
of debug what's going on.
It's a little hard to
do over video chat,
just because it's kind of different for
every user.
Sometimes your npm doesn't get installed
correctly or it does get installed,
but the system variables aren't
set correctly on your environment.
So then you just run this,
I'm not going to do it,
because I already have it installed.
And then, you'll have grunt,
or the grunt CLI.
So now the first thing we want to do,
I can actually go back to my notes here,
is, in our folder we want to run npm and
init.
I'm going to make this a little bigger.
So all the files or
all the plugins we're going to be using
with Grunt are actually installed
through the Node package manager and
they're all Node.js modules.
So the first thing we want to do
is we want to create what's called
package.JSON file, which Node basically
uses to track our tendencies.
It's pretty straightforward
if you use npm init.
It just kind of takes you through
this little walk-through guide.
I'm going to name it that,
give it that version,
my grunt demo is my description.
You probably don't need to define
an entry point or test commands.
That's the git repository.
You can give it some keywords.
You can find out what all of
these mean just by Googling npm
init walkthrough or
tutorial or whatever.
And you can find a little bit more
details about what all of these are on
the author.
Sure, let's give it and ISC license and
then it's going to basically give us
this JSON and
basically a summary in JSON form.
Just this, does this look good?
Yeah, sure that looks good and
now, if we take a look,
we see we have a package.json
file in our directory.
So basically what that allows us to do
is if we share this, if I put this up on
GitHub as a package.json and a user
just downloads it or clones the repo.
And just types in npm install, it'll
just install all of the dependencies
you need to use for
that project from the package.json file.
Looks like we had a question here.
>> So Robert was asking,
could you explain why we might
need to write sudo before our commands?
>> Okay, so sudo is basically
just like a superuser command.
If you typically, it's if you
don't have administrator access or
group access, you have to put
sudo before this command,
because it is installing it right into
the hard drive or writing to the system.
That's typically when you're
going to have to use sudo.
If you own the computer,
it's probably not a problem.
But if you're using a work computer and
there are certain things that are locked
off and you can't install specific
software, you might have to go to your
system administrator to give you
access to install these things.
Typically they're pretty lax about
installing software like this,
especially when you're
a front end developer.
Typically why you have to use sudo
commands is just because you might not
have administrator access.
>> So that's basically [INAUDIBLE].
>> Basically it just says I
am the admin, let's do this.
And usually you'll have
to type your password in.
So when you do a sudo command,
it'll just ask for your password.
>> Okay, thanks Robert.
>> Cool, so
we have our package.json set up.
I need to go back here real quick.
So now to actually install Grunt,
we're going to do command
npm install --save-dev.
And so the save dev thing is
basically this command is going to
save this dependency to our package.json
on as a developer dependency.
And so developer dependencies
are just anything that
your website doesn't
necessarily need to run,
but you as a developer are going to
use to develop your website.
And grunt is one of those things, right,
it's not a dependency that
our clients need to use.
It's really only a dependency if
we're using it to to run Grunt.
So I'm going to type in this command.
It's going to give me a little
warning that there's no data.
And then it's going to
install a bunch of stuff.
If I take a look inside,
I now have a node_modules folder.
And inside that node modules
folder is the Grunt Node module.
All right, so we have Grunt.
It can't really do anything exciting yet
because we need a Grunt file.
So I'm just going to make a Grunt file
here, and it's a JavaScript file.
And let's actually open up
our project in Sublime.
Hopefully that is big enough for
everybody to see.
I don't know if I can make my gutter,
my sidebar any bigger.
>> No.
>> But that's okay.
So we have this Grunt file now and
there's absolutely nothing in it.
And we also have, right, our JS file,
we have two JavaScript scripts and
our SASS file.
>> That's why I like this group.
>> Yes, very advanced JavaScript
going on right here and
a very advanced style going on here.
This is actually a SSS file.
This is sort of pre-processed CSS
which which we're going to use Grunts
to convert into usable CSS.
If you want to learn a lot more about
SASS, feel free to do so on your own,
I'll probably post a post on
the forums detailing how to go to SASS.
It's a really, really great language,
but I have to say, learn CSS first.
So, scroll down my
notes here real quick.
So the first thing we probably
want to do is we want to compile,
like I said, our SASS and the CSS.
That's going to be a great first step.
And in order to do that, we're going to
have to install a Grunt plugin.
So Grunt is all about plugins really.
I mean you can do a lot of the stuff
in Grunt without using any plugins, but
people have already written a lot
of code that do a lot of these
things we want to do.
And it's just easier utilizing plugins.
So we go to the Gruntjs.com page and
go to their plugin section.
You can search through all
the plugins that they have.
And any of the ones with a star next
to them are built by the Grunt team.
And they're typically fully tested,
they work, they're always up to date.
And then any one that doesn't
have a star next to it
is made by somebody else.
But there's also some really,
really good ones.
I really like the svgmin one,
I mean, for
people who like using
SVG it's fantastic.
As you can see, I mean,
there's Grunt plugins for everything.
>> A lot of Grunting.
>> There's a total of
4,403 different plugins.
>> Wow.
Yeah, and they do everything,
from watching for
changes, to manipulating code,
to to accounting.
And we're going to do
some of that today.
So, the one we're going to want is
the Grunt Sass, what did I call it?
Yeah, Grunt Sets.
How, matching records.
Let's try sas, there we go.
>> Yep.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yeah, here we go.
So, we're going to use this one.
It's not built by the grunt team,
but I like it a little bit more.
[LAUGH] And so it takes us to NPM,
the Node Package Manager website.
And it gives us a little direction
here on how to install it.
And also a few directions
on how to use it.
So, in order to install it,
we got to go back to our terminal.
And we run the command npm
install --save-dev grunt-sass.
Great.
Okay.
So, again, this is going to save it to
our so when someone else picks up our
package.json, they'll be able to
install all of our project as well.
And we'll let that magic happen.
A little slow.
All right, and it's installing.
This might take like a minute.
All right.
Cool.
We're all installed, we're set up and
we're ready to start using Grunt's app.
So, let's go back to
use of the blind text.
Also, actually,
I'm going to make this full screen.
And let's start with how do we
actually start the grunt file.
So, it's obviously a blank slate.
So, the first thing we're going to
do is we need to actually load our
grunt module.
And so the first thing we need
to create basically file mapper.
And so
this is pretty much what you're going to
start every Grunt file you create with.
And this basically just imports Grunt
to make it useable in your file.
This is just basically saying I
may use this [INAUDIBLE] All right,
so that's pretty straightforward.
That's the group wrapper.
Pretty much like this, and
like I said, he wrote probably right,
it's probably going to start with this.
The next thing we need to do is we
actually need to load our plug in.
So, to do that, we use the command
front, load and then tasks.
And then grunt-sass.
So, that's going to load our new node
module which is in our node module
folder here on SAS.
And now we can use this in our project.
So, now we need to actually
configure our task.
So we've loaded it.
Now we need to actually
give it some directions.
So we're going to do grunt.initConfig.
And this defines the initial
configuration for this grunt task.
So if we look back at the guide here,
it gives us a little directions
on how to define things.
So, we're basically just call sass.
We define the sass method.
And then we define our files
that we want to read from.
So, in this case we're going to
make our sass configuration.
We're going to say, this is
the directories we want to look in and
then we have our source directory,
which will be src/sass/style.scss and
the output destination is going to
be our dist/ css/style.css.
>> So,
you have to have this folder ready?
>> Sorry, the destination folder
doesn't need to be there.
So we can see that-
>> It will make it for you.
>> Yeah, it will automatically
make this dist/css/style.css
>> File it for me.
All right, so now we're configured.
And now there's only one more step.
We actually need to register the task.
So to register the task,
what we're going to do is,
we're going to say, grunt.register.task.
And we're going to call
this our default task.
And our default task is going to take,
it takes two parameters
this task method.
It takes the name,
which we're calling default.
And then it takes either a list or
a function.
In this case,
I'm going to pass it a list.
And in my list or array,
whatever you want to call it,
I'm going give it the name Sas.
And this is basically just saying.
Call this.
Call this growth configuration.
So it's going to all-
>> Your just surpass
>> Where is the task?
There you go.
Thank you for judging my type letters.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
this is basically just saying go and
execute this task, which is
basically going to load this grunt
sas task, and it's going to run it.
So, let's see how we run this.
So, we go back to our terminal and
all we've got to do is just say, grunt.
Woo.
All right,
running SAS disc SAS task,
done without errors.
>> Okay.
>> All right, So,
let's see what that did.
So, we now have a distribution
folder and the CSS folder,
and some file called about CSS So
basically insert my SCSS combine it and
basically compile is your CSS.
So it's really straightforward.
Pretty simple!
Let's try it one more thing.
So.
So
let's follow this pattern again, except
now, we're going to do a different task.
So we're going to concatenate
our two JavaScript files.
So, we have two JavaScript files, and
I want them to be one JavaScript file so
our users only have to do one request.
So, this is a pretty common practice.
It saves space.
It saves bandwidth and everything.
So do this.
We're going to first
install our plug-in, so
we're going to say npm
Install --save-dev.
And the plug-in I'm going to
use is grunt-contrib-concat.
We're going to run that, and it's going
to take a couple seconds to install.
Awesome.
It's ready.
We're going to load or task,
grunt.loadNpnTasks('grunt-contrib-conca-
t').
If I could spell.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
then we're going to configure our task.
So we're going to have a concat task.
We're going to give it a source folder.
In this case we're going to give it
our jobs folder and we're going to use
what's called clobbing so clobbing is
basically using a wild card characters.
Excuse me.
>> Astrid.
To say I want you to look for
any file in my
JavaScript directory
that ends with a .js.
>> So it starts just telling it you
want to get all JavaScript types.
>> Yeah.
And if you want to know like what
other sort of wildcard characters you
can use for globin,
you can go through google groups labs.
It will give you a nice
outline of all the different
the sort of target specific files.
They ask for it just has to be the most
common one because usually you just want
it all of those are all the files.
You can also get like also
hit like all sub folders.
I mean, if I had like, Js in the groups
sub folders in my base folder.
I can do something like this.
And this'll say our every folder
in my JavaScript folder and
any file that ends in .js,
I want you to do this too.
But we don't have any subfolders,
so we're not going to do that.
And then we're going to
set a destination.
So we're going to just put this in our
distribution folder, _dist/js/, and
I don't remember what I called it.
I think it was,
let's call it app.js for fun.
And then the last thing is to
remember to register our task.
There have been plenty of times when
I've gone through all of these steps and
I forgot to register it.
And I'm like why isn't it running,
why isn't running and
I go back a look at my code.
And I'm like everything looks right.
And it's all because I simply
didn't register my task.
So we'll save that.
We'll go back to our terminal and
we'll type in grunt.
And we see that it ran our SASS task,
our concat task and
it finished without errors.
And if we look back here,
we see we have that distribution folder.
JS folder and
our distribution folder and an app.js,
which concatenated
are two JavaScript files.
So really cool, so
again right that was that one, that one,
and now they're combined into one.
Now if you wants to run
a task individually, so
right now I have this default task.
And so when I type grunt,
it automatically looks for
the task named default and
runs whatever is in that.
But say I just want to run my concat,
I can do grunt concat.
And that will run, as we can see,
just my concat task.
And that can be pretty useful when
you have really big Grunt files.
Or you begin defining a lot of,
like, really complex tasks.
And Grunt can become slow if you
try running a whole a Grunt file,
it could take a couple minutes.
And all you really wanted to
do was compile JavaScript,
or compile some Coffee Script or
concatenate some JavaScript.
So usually if you named your tasks
correctly, it's pretty easy to just say
okay, just run the concat tasker,
just run the style test.
All right, so
that's the basic setup with Grunt.
You can pretty much get away
with following this workflow.
It's pretty useful I think,
if you stick with the work flow but
it can get really unorganized and
really messy.
And you may end up with a single
Grunt file that's 10,000 lines long.
Just because you're going to have to
load these tasks every time, right?
Every time you install a new plugin,
you've [INAUDIBLE].
It could get confusing in here,
what each of these is referencing.
Is this working on my JavaScript?
Is this working on my styles or
whatever?
The paths can get confusing.
Say I need to change a path or
something, or a file name, and
then I'm referencing it
a hundred times in my file.
In Sublime it's pretty easy because
I can select multiple lines,
but it's kind of a pain in
the ass to do it that way.
So let's modularize this a little bit.
Let's make this a little
bit easier to use.
So the first thing, and probably the
most useful thing I suggest everybody
does, is use a plugin
called load grunt tasks.
So we're going to say npm install
save-dev because we pretty much always
have to do this, load-grunt-tasks,
tasks with an S.
We're going to let that install.
All right, so
we see these two lines up here.
I probably don't want to have
to use these every time.
As I start installing more plugins,
I don't have to keep saying,
right, load this task.
Grunt load this task.
It's going to get really repetitive and
annoying.
So with that new plugin,
what we can do is we can simply just say
require('load-grunt-tasks') and
give it our grunt object.
And make sure you put a semicolon or
[INAUDIBLE] going to complain at me.
[SOUND] So what this is
going to do is this actually
going to look at our
Node modules folder.
It's going to look for
our dependencies and
it's going to import anything that's
work related into this object.
>> So if we take a look back here,
you can see that everything
runs fine just like before.
And now,
anytime we have to install a plugin,
we don't have to remember to login.
>> Lovely.
>> So that saves easily, 1, 10, 15, 25.
There's tons of plugins for that code.
So that makes it really simple.
And then, in that way it's
less of a step to remember.
Just like having to register a task,
it's easy to forget to load a task and
just like dive right
into the configuration.
This saves a lot of time, I feel like.
And I personally like using this
as a Grunt file, when I use Grunt.
So that's the first thing you
can do is organize the code,
clean it up a little bit more.
Additionally what we can do is we can
create a configuration file to handle
our directories.
So I mentioned before, right,
if we have a bunch of tasks.
And they're all referencing style.scss,
and
maybe I want to change
like specific tasks.
I probably am going to want to
be able to rename these quickly,
make it a little easier.
>> Mm-hm.
>> It looks like we actually
have a lot of questions?
>> Let's start with Steven's question,
and Steven asks, this is a make utility?
>> A little bit.
It's a little bit like a make utility.
So make utilities,
if I remember correctly,
are primarily from C, C++,
C# and they're more for
compiling the code,
optimizing the code, things like that.
So it's a little bit like a make tool.
I think it's a little different though.
I'm not super,
I haven't played a lot with make files.
>> Yeah.
>> But
it's kind of the same thing, yeah.
>> Okay, thanks, Steven.
Juan has another question.
Can you explain when
would concat be useful?
Would there be any performance gain?
>> Yeah so, potentially.
>> Mm-hm?
>> It depends.
So you may not necessarily want to
concatenate all your files together.
But if you have multiple
JavaScript files, say I
want to keep my production code
fairly organized and modular so
I can just open up a JavaScript file and
know exactly what I'm working on.
It's going to help a lot in the end
to just concatenate all those
files into app.js.
And that way, when the user hits,
it can request only
just one JavaScript file right off
the gate, it gets cached, whatever.
And then they don't have
to keep calling that.
Calling for different JavaScript
files every time they're
trying to run a different task,
they don't have any bunch of requests.
On the flip side,
sometimes it is nice to be able to
just cut little bit of fat
out if it's a JavaScript
function that's not going to
get called a lot, and
then just request it only when
the user I would say it depends.
But typically concat is very useful.
I tend to try to concat as many
files as I can to just kind of
get that initial page request done.
And typically you don't see a huge
hit to performance initially
on the initial page load.
So yeah.
I say it's pretty useful for pretty much
anything we'll be doing in this class,
and for
most big projects it's pretty useful.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But yeah,
just kind of play it by ear I guess,
and as Web often in browser performance
optimization class is always saying,
measure, measure, measure, measure.
Yeah.
>> Has a nice ring.
>> Always measure.
Thanks, man.
A couple of smart questions, Sean.
Jim asks,
does grunt concat work with min.js and
js files too without errors?
Or do we need to keep
them [INAUDIBLE] values?
Are other js files separate?
>> Yeah, so
it should work with min.js files.
I haven't run into a problem with it,
with anything yet.
>> I feel like he's asking for
a concat files that are minifying,
and bugs that are not minifying.
>> Yeah, yeah.
So, that will work.
I don't think I'm a very here.
But basically what would
end up happening is if
this was a minified file.
>> It would basically.
>> It would basically just shove
itself into this single line.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And so
line four would just be like this big,
long minified file.
>> Uh-huh.
>> And then this would be
sort of like the un-minified.
>> Okay.
>> You can use grunt to actually
do minification as well.
>> Mm-hm?
>> If your file's already minified,
it'll just run it through
the minifier again really fast.
But yeah,
they play pretty nice together.
Basically, all it does is just sort
of the JavaScript files together.
There's a little bit more
that goes on there but
that's sort of the rule of thumb.
>> Okay, thanks John.
Thanks John for the question.
Couple of more.
[INAUDIBLE] And there's two more,
so we had this question.
So Richard says,
the scenes decorative but
does grunt or
any dash support convention
over configuration for example-
>> Gulp.
Gulp does.
>> Gulp does.
>> He likes gulp.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
[CROSSTALK] For example, if you wanted
to use to transform images in the images
folder does it support using that
convention versus declaring the source?
Yeah so with Grunt you can do a little
bit just straight in js coding.
However it's really all
I about a config file,
grunt is very much
configuration over convention.
Whereas glup if you
want to dive into gulf or
interested in learning that,
that you're right, pure JavaScript.
It's stripped like no JavaScript and
everything.
Instead of writing this big
configuration file where I'm basically
just defining a giant JSON object.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, so, Grunt is pretty much
the philosophy of Grunt
is configuration over.
>> All right.
Thanks, Richard.
Okay.
Andrew's question is I know Gulp
is something similar to grunt.
How are they different?
And what are some pros and cons of each?
>> Okay.
So besides this, I think I mentioned
that grunt takes the kind of
configuration over coding approach.
Gulp is more you're
writing JavaScript and
less about writing a giant config file.
The other kind of major
differences between them two
is gulp is a lot faster.
Since it is all sort of running
asynchronously it really utilizes node.
And it's just streaming through node.
Where as Grunt, until I'm not sure
there's a, let me back track a bit.
So Grunt in it's current
form is very slow.
Behind the scenes it kind of sets
up a bunch of temporary holders and
handles all these tasks and
there are tons of the stuffs.
And kind of clears that out.
And then it just runs a lot
slower because of that,
because it's performing
a lot more operations.
Where as gulp is just
much more streamlined.
>> Mm-hm.
>> However Grunt has
a much bigger community.
You're probably going to more
easily find help with grunt.
And there's a lot more packages.
Although it's starting to
become a little bit closer as
gulp is gaining popularity.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The only other thing I
can think of is, with grunt,
it's easy to hand it over to someone
who doesn't know JavaScript that well.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And say like
>> Have them like set it up and
use it whereas with gulp it's
a little bit harder to hand
the file over to someone who
doesn't know JavaScript.
For them to look at it and
understand what's going on.
>> Thanks Andrew.
Okay.
A few more questions I guess,
Alexander wanted to know, can you pass
a list of source files instead of using
wildcards when you are in [INAUDIBLE]?
>> Yeah, I believe so,
let's take a look, let's go back.
I think you can give this a list.
>> Wow.
>> Script1
>> Let's see.
Source, jazz scripts.
If I can spell.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I think that works.
It's been a while since
I've tried that so see.
Yeah, yeah so
you can provide them as an array.
>> Or a list.
>> Or a list,
whatever you want to call it.
Yeah so you can do that
instead of using wildcards.
Yeah, so you can be a little bit more
precise in what you're passing along.
>> Wanted to know why not just
use NPM directly from tools?
>> You can and
I actually recommend that.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
It's maybe just a little bit more.
I think grunt and
gulp simplify things a little bit.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And they do have a lot of support.
They're really great tools.
You can do it all from
NPM directly though.
It's just a little bit more work.
>> Okay.
All right well.
>> It's very fast to do it that way.
>> One last question
before we can go back.
So asks, is there a grunt plugin for
adding unit discs?
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Unit testing with grunt is possible.
I don't, what is the plugin?
I mean there's a bunch of them.
I mean I guess it depends on what
testing environment you're using.
So like if I'm using Karma.
There's a Karma test runner.
There's one, maybe.
There's contrib-nodeunit which let's
you know which node unit unit tests.
So yeah there's a bunch of them.
And as you can see you
can just go through and
search for all kinds of them.
So yeah, there's a lot of plugins
to set up unit tests with grunt.
Same with gulp.
Thanks.
>> Yeah
>> We're done with question so
we can go back to what
we're talking about.
>> What was I talking about?
[LAUGH]
>> We were-
>> Yeah so
dealing with all these counts and
file names that are cluttering up our-
>> Yes
>> Our directory, or
sorry, our direct file here.
So what we can do is we can create Well,
it's a call, you know, a [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH]
>> So,
I'm going to make a gruntfile.yel.
And this is going to be a file that I
pretty much keep all my directories in.
So, I'm going to have it Cssdur.
And I'm going to add a word sas.
I'm going to have my
gas source directory
which is going to be right source js.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Okay.
Really bad at typing today.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Concat dir.
Our distribution for our concatenation.
And also my CSS directory which is
going to be my distribution for my CSS.
So I'm going to find
these in my enamel file.
>> Ok.
>> And in my Grunt file.
I'm going to import this configuration.
Var config equals grunt.file.readYAML.
And I'm going to read
in my grunt config.
.yml.
So now I have this
configuration variable which
contains any sort of configuration
I can find in this file.
Now you can do.
You can do allot
more than just setting up
directories with this.
So it's pretty portable and
makes things a little cleaner and nice.
And now instead of if I have a hundred
different-,
>> Tasks.
>> Tasks or something and I need to
change the name or directory for
something I can simply just change,
and it changes all of them in
here without having to mess
around too much with everything.
And if you miss one or
make a typo somewhere.
So now I can just say okay,
i want this to be my source directory.
>> Mm-hm.
>> That's what I call it.
My s.d.s.s.
I'm actually going to do this
to make things a little easier.
So i can see that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then, sorry.
That would be-
>> Yes,
I want to say config because
it's my config variable.
There you go.
And then the scssDir and
my style.js
I believe.
Right, because that's
just the directory.
>> Yeah.
>> That's the style.js.
There we go.
And
then my destination now
is just config.css.
Dir+style.css except this
is not a chance file.
[LAUGH] And then same thing here
we can just simply say config.
And then we're going to do
our JsSrcDir+ We going to
type our JS files and
then here we're going to just
desk:config.jsConcatDirand that
goon be app.js.
So that makes it a little
bit easier to go in and
sort of change where things output or
are input from.
It helps [INAUDIBLE] like I said
do a lot more and sort of your,
configure your gamble file.
Mm-hm
>> I don't know.
I don't actually probably don't
want to collect grunt file.
I wanted to call it Grunt conflict.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Otherwise it's not
going to work right because I'm.
>> Mm-hm.
>> trying to print it.
So now if we run grunt we
should see [CROSSTALK]
>> Woo-hoo.
All right cool.
So one cool thing we can do, now that
we have this defined, we can easily
lint our files as well in both sort
our source and output directory.
This is good practice because
oftentimes you have coding mistakes
in your source directory.
Or maybe you know when
you can buy almost or
something happens it breaks something
to rules and you don't want to break.
>> Mm-hm
>> So we're going to install it your
particular in use Janus hence.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So
I actually have to say this again but
were going to say npm install save dev.
Grunt-contrib-jshint.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's going to install.
And so now, right?
We don't have to load our task.
We can just say we're going
to create our jshints.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Yep.
And we're going to say.
Let's lint everything.
We're going to lint our grunt file,
It's usually good practice.
And we're going to lint
our source directory.
>> Mm hm.
>> And this jar.
>> You need to [INAUDIBLE] jar.
>> Yes.
So we're done with all our files and
we gotta remember to register it.
Otherwise it's not going to
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm going to get mad.
>> So, now we can run grunts.
We got a warning.
I'm missing a semi colon in my
>> [CROSSTALK] Grunt file.
Where am I missing my son Michael?
On line 32.
Yeah.
So cool I caught that.
And so the nice thing about that too is
in fact you should probably call your
linker first before you do any of your.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Other jobs for tasks.
That way they don't compile.
So basically this didn't run
anything because it aborted,
because there was a error.
So now grunt.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> [INAUDIBLE] done without errors.
Cool.
Now let's say we want to enforce
a specific rule with our Linter.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Let's say for
example we want to enforce that
we have to use triple equals.
>> Uh-huh.
>> All the time.
Like we don't want people to
use double equals in this case.
We can define in Options.
Attribute.
>> So this is within the Linter.
>> This is within the linter class or
jshint class or jshint [INAUDIBLE].
And so in this options, we're going to
give it an equal equal equal is true.
So JS Hint has pretty
comprehensive documentation.
>> Mm-hm.
>> On what kind of flags and
options you can put up.
I think if you go to their docs or
list of all JS hint options.
You can go in and read about
all the rules you can enforce.
And the one we're enforcing is.
EQ, EQ, EQ, this option prohibits
the use of double equals and
not equals in favor of
triple equal signs.
>> Not equal equal.
>> And not equal equal.
So let's see if this worked.
So let's go into our script, let's
save that, and let's run duramounts.
And there we go I caught that order.
It tells us that A equals,
equals B, expected triple equal.
And then [INAUDIBLE] equal.
So, we can go fix that, run Grunt.
[INAUDIBLE] Everything runs just fine.
So, that's pretty awesome.
So the last thing I want to talk
about before going out today, and
actually this repository I gave you guys
goes even a little further than this.
But the last thing I wanted to talk
about was defining a watch task.
And watch tasks are really, really cool.
So as we were doing before, basically
I'd write code and then I'd go in and
run Grunt every time I
wanted something to happen.
But say I just wanted to
focus on coding, right?
And I wanted maybe to add
some more JavaScript here and
I wanted when I saved this to
automatically run my Grunt tasks.
So what we can do is we can create
what are called watch tasks.
And as always,
we need to install a plugin.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So we're going to do npm install
--save-dev grunt-contrib-watch.
And we're going to let it install.
It's installed, we're good to go.
>> And you don't need to load it?
>> Don't need to load it
because we already did that.
And so now what we're going to do is
we're going to create a watch task.
And so in our watch task, we're
going to have different watch tasks.
In this case I'm going to
have a sass watch task.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the files that I'm going to
define here are the files
that we're watching.
So in this case, we're going to watch
our source, our sass directory.
And we're going to be
specifically looking for
anything, any subdirectory or
file that ends with scss.
Then we have to define what
tasks we're going to run.
Again this can be a function or
I believe,
actually I think it has to be an array.
And we're going to
call our sass function.
We also could call another function so
I could call jshint as well out here and
it will execute both
of these on a change.
But obviously since we're editing
a sass file we don't need to it.
So let's do that and
also don't forget to register it.
So before, when we ran a task write,
it said done without errors.
Let's see what happens this time.
So I call Grunt, hopefully no errors.
Alright, there we go.
Now it says running watch task, waiting.
>> Okay.
>> So let's see what happens.
Let's go in here and
get rid of this important tag because
we probably shouldn't be using those.
I save it and we see that file
has changed running this task.
Done without errors and
now it's waiting again for more change.
If we take a look here, we can see that
our important has left the building.
Let's add another thing.
Let's say block.
Let's do HTML, height 100%.
Save it.
Go back to our style and there we go.
Automatically compiled.
Grunt ran that task because
we're watching that file.
So watch tasks are really
really really awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> You can even set up watch tasks
that will watch your JavaScript.
You can set up watch tasks that'll
basically just recompile over
any task you want when
certain files change.
And it becomes really, really useful
when you want to just be able to focus
on coding and not have to worry about
minifying everything all the time,
and having to switch back and
forth between those.
So that's about all we have time for
today.
I had actually a lot more planned.
But I'll put those up on the forum so
you can feel free to follow
along with the rest.
The rest is a little advanced.
You don't necessarily have to do that.
What I showed you here today is probably
enough to get you started with Grunt and
get you using it pretty reasonably.
If you have any questions, though,
feel free to post on the forum and
you can add me directly
in the post @johnmav.
That's J-O-H-N-M-A-V.
And, yeah.
Unless we have any other questions,
I think we might call it a wrap for
the day.
How did that go,
did I do a good job there?
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was wonderful.
I hope you all felt
the same way as I did.
>> Yeah, so like I said,
Grunt is going to be really,
really useful in the future.
I don't know a front end
workflow stack developer
who doesn't use it or something similar.
Like I said Grunt and
Gulp are the two most popular, but
there's millions of them out there.
I know, kind of an up and
coming one that I haven't had a chance
to fully use yet is Broccoli?
>> Yeah.
>> But it looks pretty promising.
But it's still very new and
it doesn't have a lot of support yet,
so it probably is not
as easy to learn about.
But there's you know hundreds
of these different [CROSSTALK]
>> [CROSSTALK] another vegetable?
I forget.
>> There might be another vegetable one.
>> [CROSSTALK].
>> All these crazy [INAUDIBLE],
crazy things.
Grunt, Gulp, Broccoli.
>> Thank you Adam.
Ann says great job.
>> Thank you.
All right cool.
So thank you everybody for
joining us today.
>> We'll see you next Monday?
>> Next Monday?
Yeah.
>> And
we're going to meet another teacher.
>> Yeah, more teachers, woo hoo.
>> Yep.
>> Awesome.
All right thanks everybody.
>> Thank you.
Bye.